Most people facing the death
penalty don't pick their lawyer.
They may be fortunate to have
a lawyer who is a caring,
competent,
hardworking person with a enough of a
caseload or reasonable workload that they
can provide the representation that's
required in a death penalty case.
On the other hand,
a poor person accused of a crime
involving the death pony may be assigned a
lawyer who's completely incompetent,
uh,
who has 300 400 cases and can't possibly
spend the time that's required to
defend a capital case.
They may be assigned a lawyer who
doesn't know the law regarding capital
punishment.
So that law might as well not
exist for this particular client.
So we'll take a look at the quality
of representation provided to people,
uh,
in death penalty cases,
because often the lawyer assigned to a
case is the determining factor on whether
somebody gets the death penalty or not.
Uh,
some states have capital defender offices.
Colorado has had one for a long time.
It has only two or three people
usually on death row at any time,
because that office has been so effective
in representing people and preventing
imposition of the death
pony in those cases.
On the other hand,
you have states like Texas and Alabama
that have no public defender system,
even not to mention a
capital defender office.
So if you're facing the death
plenty in one of those states,
and there are a number of
them all across the country,
uh,
it may be that the lawyer is the
lawyer from private practice.
It may be the lawyer doesn't
have an investigator.
Uh,
it may be the court doesn't provide
funding for experts or other,
uh,
essential,
aspects of defending a case.
Uh,
and the result is that person is to put
it mildly at a tremendous disadvantage,
uh,
facing the death penalty.
A number of examples of this are
provided@asecondclassjustice.com.
Um,
in this segment,
we're gonna look at a few examples
and explore the reasons why people,
uh,
can be condemned to die despite a
grossly incompetent legal representation.
Uh,
generally the right to counsel
is determined not before trial.
Does this person have a competent lawyer
who's going to represent them at the
trial but is determined after the trial
when the question is raised looking
backwards at the trial,
did the person have effective
assistance of counsel?
And we'll talk about how
the court has defined that,
uh,
in a way that makes it possible to
say a person was not defined effective
assistance of counsel even
when it's questionable,
whether even when a demonstrably,
uh,
is,
is not true.
Uh,
generally that's the way.
There's some exceptions.
There have been lawsuits filed,
uh,
to improve representation in,
criminal cases by,
uh,
dealing with case loads or
other systemic problems.
But for the most part in capital cases,
particularly what we're going to see
is an after the fact looked back at the
representation that someone had.
And I want to use the case out
of Oklahoma of James Fisher,
uh,
as an example.
Uh,
he was tried in 1983 and represented by
a lawyer who not only represented James
Fisher,
but tried 24 other cases
during the month of September.
Hard to imagine that one
lawyer could try 24 cases.
He put on no evidence and said only nine
words during the sentencing phase of
James Fisher's trial.
Uh,
the case went to the Oklahoma
Court of criminal appeals,
which said it was deeply disturbed
by the representation that Fisher had
received,
but nonetheless,
it wasn't disturbed enough,
uh,
that it gave him a new trial.
It upheld both the conviction
and the death penalty.
Uh,
in the case,
uh,
many years later,
2002,
the United States courts of the United
States Court of appeals finds that the
lawyer failed to investigate what
was a close case in terms of weather.
Fisher was actually the person
who committed this crime or not,
that the lawyer was grossly
inept and disloyal to Fisher,
uh,
by,
the hostility,
uh,
that he showed towards his
client and his client's case.
So now,
many years,
1983,
the trial,
2002,
the United States appellate court
is saying Fisher gets a new trial.
Uh,
2005,
he has his second trial.
This time,
Fisher gets a lawyer who
was drinking heavily,
uh,
and uh,
abusing cocaine.
Uh,
at one point the lawyer threatened Fisher,
actually asked the deputies to take off
the handcuffs so he and Fisher could
have a fist fight.
Uh,
this is about as bad as it gets.
An attorney client relations,
uh,
no investigation whatsoever.
Fishers is sends to death,
yet again,
a 2009 this time the Oklahoma
Court of criminal appeals says no,
this was ineffective lawyering,
ineffective at the guilt phase.
And the court said Fisher was prejudice
because the prosecution's case was not
very strong and other words,
Fisher.
Now in 2009,
having been synced to death,
has spent over 20 years,
most of it on death row.
And there's never been a constitutional
determination of whether he's actually
guilty of the crime or not.
Because his first lawyer did nothing for
him and his second lawyer did nothing
for him.
He did not have a,
uh,
a fighting chance of presenting his case
and contesting new government's case at
either one of these trials.
In 2010.
The prosecution agrees that Fisher can
be released only if he would admit guilt
and agree to be banished
from Oklahoma forever.
Uh,
if you're James Fisher and you've
had the two trials that he's had,
the trial were,
the lawyer only said nine
words at the penalty phase,
the trial where the lawyer tried to
get in a fist fight with him and was
drinking and abusing cocaine,
um,
it's awfully hard to turn that deal down.
Uh,
we see this in a number of death penalty
cases to get reversed where when they
come back,
the prosecution wants to save face,
but knows it probably can't get a
conviction the defendant wants out,
but knows there's some risk that they
may be convicted again and regardless
they're going to stay in jail for some
period of time before the new trial.
So they end up taking this sort of,
uh,
deal,
where they agree to plead guilty sometimes
of pleading guilty while maintaining
their innocence,
uh,
in exchange for time served basically,
and they're set free.
Uh,
this case is a disgrace.
It's a disgrace that the trial judge
didn't stop it at the first trial,
that the trial judge didn't
stop it at the second trial,
and that it took this many years
for James Fisher's right to counsel,
uh,
to be vindicated.
Uh,
but it's not that unusual.
Gregory Wilson since to death,
uh,
in Kentucky was represented by a
lawyer who practiced out of his home.
Um,
you may say a lawyer could
practice out of his home,
although this was back in the days
before a laptop computers and the kind of
technological advantages we have today
that make it possible for lawyer to
practice out of his or her home.
Uh,
in this case,
uh,
the lawyers home had a
big Budweiser beer sign,
uh,
up on the wall in the living room.
Uh,
Wilson found out,
Wilson found out that just a short
time before the police had gone to this
office or home of the lawyer and had
taken up the floor in the living room and
taking out eight bags of stolen property.
But what really was the final Straw for
Gregory Wilson was when he called the
telephone number.
The lawyer gave him in
the answered Kelly's Keck.
Uh,
Kelly's keg is a bar right across the
street from the Kenton County courthouse
in Kentucky where Gregory Watson
was tried and it actually worked.
I mean,
if you call the number for Kelly's Cag,
the bartender would answer and often
summon the lawyer William Hagadorn,
uh,
to the phone.
Uh,
but unfortunately he may
not remember that call.
The next day when Wilson gets to court,
he says to the judge,
your honor,
I want a new lawyer and I'm
facing the death penalty.
I'm from Detroit,
I'm in Kentucky.
I'm a black man facing the death penalty
and a place where I don't know anybody
and I need a real lawyer.
The judge says,
well,
Mr. Wilson,
you can have any lawyer you want,
but this is your court appointed lawyer,
Mr Hegg door.
Uh,
so if you want to bring in another lawyer,
of course,
wasn't,
had no ability to bring in another lawyer.
Uh,
and as a result,
he went to trial,
uh,
with Mr Headquarters is lawyer.
Uh,
he was,
it was a somewhat farcical trial.
He was sentenced to death.
Uh,
and in the review process later,
the courts rejected his claim that he
had not been adequately represented,
saying that Wilson had failed
to cooperate with Mr Hegg door.
Of course he was trying to get Mr Hegg
Dorn replaced during all that time.
The question you ask if this case is
how does a person like Gregory Wilson in
force the right to counsel the most
fundamental right a person accused of a
crime or facing the death penalty has,
what do you do when the
lawyer is incompetent?
And you can tell the
lawyers and competent.
But this is the judge,
the lawyer the judge gave you.
Uh,
and so here we see an example of when the
most fundamental right a person has is
actually a unenforceable,
even though it's hard to imagine what
else Gregor Woodson could have done a than
what he did and trying
to get a new lawyer.
Uh,
Jeffery Leonard was tried by a lawyer
who knew so little about him that he was
tried under the name James Slaughter.
His lawyer didn't even
know his client's name.
Uh,
he had used this,
came slaughter as an alias and had been
arrested under that name of the lawyer.
Didn't know that he was brain damage.
Uh,
the lawyer did not know a whole lot.
I didn't know anything actually about
his client and when the case was being
heard.
And the lawyer testified
about his experience,
he claimed that he had been a prosecutor
in New York and that he had tried to
the death point of cases
turned out those were not true.
Uh,
he later resigned from the bar in a deal,
uh,
because,
of his misrepresentations,
but the courts all the way through the
state and federal courts upheld the death
sins for Jeffery Leonard.
He was spared execution only
because the governor of Kentucky,
Ernie Fletcher commuted his sentence,
uh,
when,
when he left office.
Uh,
another example is Hollywood,
uh,
Iq in the low sixties.
This is an intellectually disabled person
who's tried in Alabama and sentenced
to death.
And it turns out that the
lawyers representing him,
local lawyers never bothered to go to
the school where Hollywood had been in
special education classes.
The special education classes were
held in the basement of the school.
Whether the electricity often didn't work.
It also flooded every time it rained
and it was called by the other students,
the mole hole.
And Hollywood was one of the moles.
Uh,
this would have probably been critical
evidence if the jury had only heard it,
uh,
that he had an Iq in the low sixties
that he had been in special education,
whatever one can say,
uh,
about someone faking mental illness.
You can't fake,
uh,
an Iq in the 60s.
At the time we were in grade school.
Uh,
and anticipation that many,
many years later you might
face the death public,
uh,
inadequate representation.
Nevertheless,
Alabama courts held that the lawyers
made a reasonable decision not to
investigate,
uh,
and go to the school and talk to the
teachers and find out what was right there
in town,
uh,
and,
that that was a reasonable decision.
Alabama executed Hollywood in 1960.
There are many other examples.
I mean,
if you go to Texas,
uh,
three death penalty cases in which
the lawyer slept during the trial,
uh,
judges presiding over cases where the
lawyer representing the person facing the
death pony is asleep,
even snoring in some cases,
one of the judges was
asked by a journalist,
how can you preside over a case
where the defense lawyer is asleep,
uh,
and trying the case?
And the judge said,
wow,
the constitution guarantees you a lawyer.
Uh,
but it doesn't guarantee you
that the lawyer has to be awake.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
Calvin Verdeyen,
to other people since to
death and Kevin Burdens case,
the case goes to the United
States Court of Appeals.
And the state of Texas argues that,
uh,
even though the lawyer,
Joe Cannon,
who also slept in another death point of
case and was an older lawyer who often
slept after lunch when he tried cases,
and yet the judges in Houston continued
to appoint him to case after case.
Texas made the argument that,
well,
this was not inadequate loitering
or ineffective lawyer in,
because after all,
the court upheld cases where the
lawyers run of the influence of alcohol,
uh,
drugs,
even a case where a lawyer has all timers.
Uh,
but the court decided that a sleeping
lawyer was unconscious and so was
therefore unlike the alcoholic Liam
paired lawyer or the drug impaired lawyer,
uh,
and found that a burden was
entitled to a new new trial.
Another cannon,
a client,
another person represented
by Joe Frank Cannon.
Uh,
Carl Johnson was executed by the
state of Texas and George Macfarlane,
who was represented by John Ben,
another lawyer who actually snored,
uh,
during the trial,
is,
is still on death row in Texas,
another lawyer in Texas,
his drone guide notes who practices in
Houston and who in three different death
penalty cases has missed the deadline for
filing a federal Habeas Corpus action.
So about as basic a responsibility
as a lawyer has in any kind of case,
whether it's an automobile negligence
case or any other kind of case file within
the deadline filed within
the statute of limitations,
he missed it.
Not once,
you would've thought that would've been
enough to suspend them from practice.
Not twice but three times.
And yet the state bar
of Texas did nothing.
The Texas Court of criminal
appeals did absolutely nothing.
The trial judge's in Houston did nothing.
In fact,
he's still being appointed
to criminal cases,
including capital cases in Texas.
Today.
You're not very lucky if you
get this guy as your lawyer.
Uh,
not very lucky at all.
and yet nothing has been done despite
what really should be a basis for some
disciplinary action by the bar in terms
of missing the statute of limitations.
How can it be,
uh,
that,
this happens,
uh,
in cases?
Well,
the Supreme Court held 1942 in a case
called Glasser versus United States.
That the right to counsel
is two fundamental,
an absolute for courts to indulge in
Nice calculations as to the amount of
prejudice from its denial.
In other words,
if somebody has denied
the right to a lawyer,
that's so fundamental,
we can't get into whether the case
would have come out the same way or not.
We've got to give them a new trial.
The court changed its mind,
uh,
and decided actually courts could make
a fairly rough calculation of what
difference it made.
A,
in the case of Strickland
versus Washington in 1984,
this was a death penalty case.
David Washington was sentenced to death
in Florida and had raised the fact that
his lawyer had done virtually nothing
to prepare for the penalty phase of his
case.
Uh,
the Supreme Court said that a lawyer
is not ineffective if the judges can
conclude after looking at the case
that it didn't make any difference,
that the lawyers in competence
didn't make any difference.
If the court asks this question,
is there a reasonable probability that,
but for the lawyers performance,
the deficient performance,
the result would be different.
In other words,
do the acts and omissions of the lawyer
undermine confidence in the outcome of
the case?
Uh,
this is the,
uh,
prejudice,
prom Strickland versus Washington.
There are two parts of it.
I'm going to take the prejudice part first
because this is where the court said,
uh,
that judges can decide.
And other words,
even though a lawyer may be incompetent,
I've judge can say there was no violation
of the right to counsel because the
judge concludes that the case
would come out the same way,
even if the person had been
represented by competent counsel.
Chris,
very hard for judges to know that,
uh,
they weren't there at the trial.
Uh,
they didn't hear the witnesses.
they weren't sitting in the jury and they
didn't know how the jury assessed the
case.
And yet every day courts decide to uphold
cases where people have head deficient
legal representation,
uh,
on the basis that there's not
a substantial probability that,
but for the representation
the person received a,
they would have gotten the death penalty.
Uh,
so even though courts are saying lawyers
are not quote ineffective legally,
they're not saying or the lawyer can
still be incompetent but not legally and
effective.
And so as a result,
it's a way in which courts can paper
over the poorer quality representation.
Uh,
that happens in many cases,
capital and non capital as well.
The other part of the test is,
was the performance of
the lawyer deficient.
And the court has said that's
measured by what our prevailing,
uh,
professional norms did.
The lawyer's representation meet whatever
the sort of standard of care in the
legal profession is for representing
somebody in a death penalty case.
Now,
that would be a,
an objective assessment.
But the court added a couple or three
things to make it very difficult to
conclude,
uh,
that the lawyers performance
fell below the standard.
Uh,
first of all,
the court said judicial review.
It's going to be highly deferential.
In other words,
the judges are not to second
guess lawyers as a general matter.
Uh,
the courts are to indulge
a strong presumption that
the lawyer rendered adequate
assistance.
In other words,
regardless of whether
the lawyer did or not,
the of course are going to presume that
the lawyer was adequate and made all
significant decisions based
upon professional judgment.
The lawyer may have been
completely clueless,
but the Supreme Court says,
we'll presume that any
decision not to call a witness,
not to do an investigation,
not to do whatever was a professional
decision and tactical decisions or
strategic choices made after
thorough investigation,
which may or may not be an issue in some
cases are virtually on challengeable.
So what the court is basically doing
here is making it fairly hard for a court
considering a claim of
ineffective loitering,
uh,
to find the lawyer a deficient in the
performance because of these presumptions,
although they can be overcome and
they are from time to time in cases.
Uh,
but then the court can also decide,
as I talked about a moment ago,
uh,
that it didn't have an
effect on the outcome.
It was,
we're all been the same.
Uh,
and there we'd be,
well,
a Justice Marshall descents,
uh,
he says this standard is so malleable,
it will either have no grip at all or
there will be all kind of variations.
In other words,
there won't really be a
standard of representation,
a four people,
uh,
in,
in these cases.
Uh,
and he also says this presumption,
all these presumptions put a very heavy
burden of persuasion on the WHO's been
convicted or sentenced to death,
uh,
and says there,
once you show back to what
the court had said in Glasser,
once a determination is made that the
lawyers performance was deficient,
then that should be the end.
The court shouldn't indulge in this
speculation about whether or not it made a
difference.
Let me take one case to just illustrate,
uh,
what,
what happens here that the,
the judicial rulings on denial of
council in the state courts are made by
elected judges.
Uh,
often the very same judges,
uh,
who appointed the lawyer
in the first instance.
It's not always but often the case,
uh,
and then reviewed on Habeas
Corpus by the federal courts,
life tenure judges.
But they can set aside a conviction only
if they conclude that the decision of
the State Court,
which is where almost all these cases
come from was an unreasonable application
of Strickland versus Washington or was
contrary to Strickland versus Washington.
Let's take a look at
Robert [inaudible] case.
Um,
this was a man since to death in Georgia.
It turns out that his lead defense lawyer,
uh,
drank a quart quart of vodka every night
during the trial because he was getting
ready to be indicted and ultimately
disbarred and ultimately convicted,
uh,
for,
stealing client funds.
The lawyer said he probably shouldn't
been allowed to represent anybody.
Uh,
during this time period.
he didn't present.
This man is intellectually disabled,
but no evidence was presented about that.
Uh,
he had been subject to,
this is from judge Bork cats to said
that he was subject to abuse that was so
severe,
so frequent,
and so notorious that his neighbors
called his childhood home.
The torture chamber.
All of this evidence not presented by
this lawyer who's drinking a quart of
vodka every day during a capital trial,
uh,
Georgia trial judge says,
no one can seriously believe that Hosely
received the constitutional guarantee
of the right to council.
It seems pretty obvious.
Uh,
but the Georgia Supreme Court says,
well,
there's no substantial probability
that the case would have come out
differently.
That even if he had had a sober lawyer,
even if he had had a lawyer to put
on all this evidence about his mental
limitations,
about the abuse he received as a child,
we,
the Georgia Supreme Court justices
don't think it would have come out any
differently.
And the United States Court of
Appeals for the 11th circuit says,
well,
we defer to the Georgia Supreme Court.
Uh,
it's not an unreasonable application
of Strickland versus Washington because
fair minded jurists can disagree,
uh,
with regard to it.
Uh,
so in other words,
even though the trial judge who saw
the witnesses and heard about this,
found that a violation of the right to
counsel the Georgia Supreme Court doesn't
make any finding that the lawyer was
on vodka and about to be indicted was
competent.
They just find that it would've
made any difference if he had had,
uh,
another lawyer in his case.
So just as James Fisher,
uh,
would probably be denied under
the law as it is today if the,
if you had this deference that
was applied and Jose's case,
uh,
Robert Hosely probably would have
received a new trial if his case had been
before the federal
courts back at the time.
Fisher's case was before the United
States Court of Appeals for the 10th
circuit.
In other words,
when these cases came
before the federal courts,
one was when the law did not require
deference to state court findings.
That's Fisher.
And he got a new trial
and he's a free man today.
Holst Lee's comes before the court.
Uh,
when the courts do have to defer the
federal courts to the state courts and
because of this restraint,
we're causing this deference.
He loses.
So timing is everything.
They're going to be a lot of.
Robert Holst was a lot of people who are,
and there are a lot who are sends
to death who the state courts say,
well the Lord may not have been great
but we don't think it would've made a
difference.
Uh,
and the federal courts then are going
to apply this deferential standard of
review basically as Justice Marshall
predicted in his dissent and strictly,
uh,
this standard has turned
out to be so malleable,
uh,
that it's an eye of the beholder standard.
Some judges will look at a lawyer's
performance and say this was deficient.
It affected the outcome.
The person's entitled for new trial.
Another judge will look at
the same set of facts and say,
we don't think it made any difference.
And if you're a federal judge,
you can even say,
well,
we may not agree with
the state court decision.
We may not agree with the
Georgia Supreme Court,
but it's not unreasonable because
fair minded judges can disagree.
And if fair minded judges can disagree,
then we're going to,
uh,
let the state courts decide.
The reason this is so important and
we'll talk about judges at another time,
uh,
is because the state
court judges are elected.
Uh,
and very often the decision making
in the state courts is influenced,
uh,
as justice Stevens has
recognized it's just a soda.
My IRS recognized,
uh,
by the political pressure
that's often present.
Uh,
when you have elected
judges to signing cases,
the federal judges,
uh,
life tenure judges have a
little more independence.
Um,
can prejudice be presumed?
Uh,
this is an interesting case
that was decided the same
day that the Washington or
Strickland versus
Washington case was decided.
Manny,
Moe Harrison chronic,
uh,
is the government spends four and a half.
The United States government spends four
and a half years getting his case ready
for trial.
Uh,
it's,
he's charged with 13
counts of check kiting.
Uh,
and the case involves thousands of
documents about how there's check kiting
scheme worked.
Uh,
and he's given a real estate lawyer who
had never tried a case 25 days before
trial.
Look at this.
The government's been four and
a half years getting ready,
and his lawyer has 25 days
to get ready for trial.
The lower court looked at this and said,
well,
I mean,
of course this couldn't
possibly be a lawyer,
couldn't possibly represent somebody.
In this situation,
a supreme court unanimously
reversed and said,
we're not going to presume a prejudice.
Uh,
in this case,
uh,
we are going to require that the court
looks at it under the Washington versus
Strickland standard.
In other words,
we're going to look at
the lawyer's performance,
was it the deficient performance?
And secondly,
uh,
was there any prejudice as a result,
a chronics case was sent
back to the lower court.
It actually found that even
under the Strickland standard,
uh,
he was ineffective.
The lawyer was ineffective.
Uh,
he was given a new trial.
He was convicted to the new trial,
but on appeal,
the court said there wasn't even
sufficient evidence to convict him.
And he double jeopardy principles,
uh,
prevented him from being tried again.
Uh,
again,
that case might not come out the same way,
uh,
today.
Uh,
but of course this is a case
out of the United States,
uh,
prosecuted by the United States.
So it's not quite the same,
uh,
as the,
as the state cases that are reviewed,
uh,
on Habeas Corpus,
um,
for the most part,
the denial,
the court's going to make clearer,
didn't make clear in a number of
cases after this that very seldom will
prejudice be presumed.
In the Calvin Verdeyen case,
which I mentioned where the
lawyers slept during the trial,
the United States states court of Appeals
for the fifth circuit sitting with a
whole court held that there they would
presume prejudice because a lawyer who
was asleep was basically
absent from the trial.
And a sleeping lawyer is
really no lawyer at all.
And therefore we will presume prejudice.
Of course,
that's an extraordinary kind of case.
That's not your typical case
where there's a sleeping lawyer.
There may be a very bad lawyer,
but usually the lawyers can manage
to stay awake during the trial.
Uh,
so generally the cases are going
to be looked at under strict one.
Again,
it's going to be very much
the courts that look at it.
Uh,
the political pressures that come to bear,
the very deferential standard of
assessing whether or not the lawyer's
performance was deficient or not.
And then finally of course decision
about is there a substantial probability?
Do we think it made a difference,
a substantial probability
that it affected the outcome.
As a result,
many people who receive
inadequate representation,
uh,
are not going to have
their cases set aside,
uh,
and are going to be executed.
Of course,
there are going to be some cases and
there were cases decided by the United
States Supreme Court,
uh,
the Williams case out of Virginia,
Terry Williams,
where the court held that there
was an effective representation,
the Wiggins case out of Maryland,
again,
where the court found in
effective representation,
but,
and,
and the,
uh,
Ron pillowcase from polo
versus beer where again,
the United States Supreme Court
found ineffective representation.
But against those cases,
you find case after case,
including a number of cases where the
Supreme Court has just granted a review of
a case and reversed a grant of
ineffective assistance of counsel.
And we see many courts in the country
where it's almost impossible to prevent,
to excuse me,
to prevail on a claim of
ineffective assistance of counsel.
What does this mean going forward?
It means that people facing the death
penalty may have the good fortune to have
good lawyers,
well trained lawyers,
capable lawyers,
uh,
but they may also not.
And if they don't,
uh,
there may be no relief for them.